Barry Nasser was sentenced to more time
behind bars yesterday after being
confronted by more than 150 girls and
women who say he abused them they
testified during a sentencing hearing
for Nasser that lasted seven days
Kyle Stephens the first accuser to speak
says Nasser's started molesting her when
she was just six years old
the first victim to come forward rachel
den Hollander was a 15 year old gymnast
when Nasser first treated her here are
some of what they said in court
Larry sexually assaulted me repeatedly
under the guise of medical treatment for
nearly a year
as the only non-medical victim to come
forward I testified to let the world
know that you are a repulsive liar this
is what it looks like when institutions
create a culture where a predator can
flourish unafraid and unabated sexual
abuse is so much more than a disturbing
physical act
it changes the trajectory of a victims
life and that is something that no one
has the right to do children are worth
everything worth every protection the
law can offer little girls don't see a
little forever they grow into strong
women that return to destroy your world
Rachel Rachel rather den holder and Kyle
Stephens are with us along with dr. Jon
LaPook was covered the Nasr case and
joins us at the table welcome so glad
that you're joining us this is very
important and very serious Rachel I want
to start with you because the judge said
that you were the bravest person to ever
enter her courtroom she was very clear
on how she felt she said he wasn't even
she wouldn't even allow him to treat her
dogs and I want to know what made you
come forward all those years ago what
did you know was wrong or what did you
think was wrong well there are a few
times that NASA crossed a line
that I was certain with sexual assault
but at that age I was very convinced
that this was not something that could
ever be done quietly and anonymous voice
wouldn't be enough NASA was backed by
two very powerful institutions and I was
aware of 15 of the dynamics of sexual
assault you know that there's there's
never only one victim and it was
something he had been doing regularly
that was clear and so it was it was
unthinkable that there were not other
victims who had come forward and who had
been silenced and I was right women
had been raising the alarm four years
before I walked in Larry store and had
been silenced it was not until we were
able to put the public pressure on both
of those institutions to take the
allegation seriously that other victims
felt safe enough to come forward and we
were able to stop him Kyle you also
began raising concerns about Larry
Nasser he was a family friend yeah I I
didn't know there were other victims I
worried that there were but because I
was perpetrated in a setting where I
didn't know that there was a potential
for that when you're a patient obviously
there's tons of more female patients but
I had no who did you report his behavior
to I reported his behavior to my parents
and my parents reported it to a Michigan
State doctor and professor did your
parents believe you at first no didn't I
didn't disclose all the details of my
abuse it's obviously very uncomfortable
and so my parents just thought it was
strange what I was saying and they they
chose not to believe me
Rachel given how uncomfortable it is to
go through these details what was it
like to hear so many other people
testify all in that courtroom you know
it was it was empowering and it was
beautiful to see so many women
reclaiming their voice but it was also
incredibly heartbreaking because the
vast majority of us did not need to be
there had those first reports to MSU had
coached Kathy clay guess in 1997 been
taken seriously the vast majority of
victims would have not been in that
courtroom and I think that's one of the
most troubling things is that there you
have been strong women and strong girls
from the beginning reporting this
behavior but it has been the silence of
people in power that allowed it to
continue his USA Gymnastics how did they
allow him to prey on other gymnasts you
know USA Gymnastics had is really an
organization that's rotting from the
inside out
they created a culture of physical
psychological and mental abuse but they
also had a policy of not reporting
sexual predators at the time I was being
abused up until I came forward and some
of this corruption began to be revealed
they would systematically file reports
of sexual assault against member coaches
in a file cabinet so when you have a
culture that is abusive and then you
have a policy of not reporting sexual
abuse you have create
the perfect dynamic for a predator to be
able to flourish we should say that USA
USA Gymnastics did release a statement
they say the highest priority is a
safety health and well-being of its
athletes that's unsupported yeah
absolutely
you know it's director Penney testified
under oath at one point and actually
defended this policy of not reporting
sexual abuse because he said he couldn't
wanted to avoid a witch-hunt
you know when an organization
characterizes people who report sexual
abuses potential witch hunters that
really tells you everything you need to
know about how safe it is to come
forward yeah dr. Larry now surrogates
175 years is that enough not just for
him is shouldn't more people pay the
price for this we have to point out
Sally Jenkins amazing article in The
Washington Post I encourage everybody to
read it because you look at that and you
see how this went on for so many years
so shouldn't more people pay or do you
believe more people should pay other
than Larry Nasser there absolutely has
to be accountability
if we don't institute accountability if
we don't learn from the mistakes that
were made and make it clear that that
the price for making these mistakes is
going to be very severe we're just going
to keep repeating this cycle of abuse
Jon what's most egregious to you in this
case this is a good time for me to be
listening but I would just say this has
occurred on a cultural canvass that has
a huge problem with sexual abuse of
children it's estimated that more than
60,000 children are abused every year
and a third of them are under the age of
12 so we need to do a lot of work a lot
of homework and this needs much further
investigation something that it happens
repeatedly that's what I that's what I
can't get over that so many people knew
about it and allowed it to continue for
many years yeah these institutions are
diseased and they need to recognize that
their disease that's part of the problem
is up till this week they've been
refusing to recognize what's going on in
their ranks and they need to clean house
and what did you think in Larry Nasser
statement when he said this is
fabrication
these are women scorned Larry Nasser is
a master manipulator mm-hmm but I think
you saw that very clearly in the
courtroom I want to ask you Rachel I
noticed you addressed the court and then
at the very last second you turn to the
right to return
and you shot Nasir a look that could
have melted iron what was going through
your head I wanted him to know that it
was done it was finished and that you
were both still standing we thank you
very much for coming yeah just thank you
there you realize you have unleashed a
tsunami of change I hope so yeah I
believe so too Nora thank you all